yeah welcome to this video plays master
Istani wish that Alex Astana Lopez okay
let's do some fianchetto here double
fear in Cairo it's fear keto not
fianchetto but i still like fianchetto
so let's do this this is a funny line
where black has to be very very alert
not to lose quickly so we see how he how
he fares him which I eggs and no hmm
this is actually a little bit better
than some other continuations that black
might might choose what is best here
maybe just taking
okay maybe I steak pan 93 m yeah this is
some much better version than some of
the other possible ways to play this
here black seems reasonably okay
a 94 maybe is a multi tasking of one
that isn't a problem at all
yeah that looks very equal
bishop's is six maybe
no hmm that looks I know see really
ambitious here in this position let's
see if I can get in 95 that was the idea
it seems don't quite get it so let's say
king of two right I mean I don't quite
get it seems a bit negative I just don't
see where it leads i think
just just that does this end game can
never be something for for black to dry
because I just have the better minor
p.m. and then said I think it's just
equal
trying to invade with the king that's
still something that I can try to a six
I think but what whites advantage she is
probably not super serious
so I'm to to him
Jeff don't get that sorry I do
absolutely I don't get what he's doing
here it just seems like a way to apply
for play for a loss here it's giving me
an outside passer why would you do that
that's something I would check will he
go I mean I really try to go through
some lengths to get it and he just gives
it to me it's quite quite surprising
hmm strange
I have this ideas to invade on the
queenside before followed by King b-52 a
six
yeah I wonder if this is still
defensible here are already already too
bad
okay so if i go before how it I don't
get it and I don't get any with him
maybe it was so bad that she felt he
needed to do that but I just take care
and what is the point Jeff
a five okay um probably here I'm not
trading so much let's bring that up okay
check here and then I cannot so easily
invade
I am giant Bishop f three years okay
should we have three
so let's see King d5 and then yeah I
should be okay threatening King c6 so
chick CA allows me to take that now any
problem with that I don't see it so
let's get the beep on
black resigns yeah well what I didn't
get is here he has just equalized and I
didn't understand why why he went
deliberately for for the same game here
because it wasn't absolutely necessary
he had a very comfortable position right
here he could for example play I thought
Bishop c6 and this is just totally equal
like this this and nothing happens yeah
nothing happens maybe this is maybe a
smidgen yeah i can i can activate a
little bit easier but it's it's it's
totally equal probably or very little
yeah and he deliberately went into
bishop against night and here white only
can be better and it's it's not so easy
to learn to defend this but this is this
is really stranger why did he give me he
provoked me to get get an outside
passion and it is a strange idea why
would you do that check yeah and this is
also not helping maybe this for night
Jeff five but let's say I go here he
goes see and I can I can try to invade
now like this maybe a five yeah and he
has enough counter play that that just
lets may be possible that could be
enough with the econ here and I'm
getting a seven the problem is always
nights nights against the flank pawns
yeah I might get a and H porn or
something I know it's just it's just a
very it's just difficult to defend and
there's nothing to gain let's say yeah
and II for just gave away the pawn I
mean after that I'm definitely winning
so in such acts really strange really
strange way of conducting the endgame
term it's just much easier to
here on to avoid this this Bishop
against nine situation and play a player
let's say Bishop c6 I think here it was
easy as just Bishop c6 or even root c8
as possible now that's not necessary
let's do this let's simplest keep the
distribution of minor pieces completely
identical that's an easy way to to get
equality ok well thanks for watching